foreign
I'd like to start by asking you to
imagine a color that you've never seen
before
just for a second give this a try
can you actually visualize a color that
you've never been able to perceive
I never seem to get tired of trying this
although I know it's not an easy
Challenge and the thing is we can
imagine something without drawing upon
our experiences
a color we haven't yet seen outside the
Spectrum we can perceive is outside our
ability to conjure up
it's almost like there's a boundary to
our imagination where all the colors we
can imagine can only be various shades
of other colors we had previously seen
yet we know for a fact that those color
frequencies outside our visible spectrum
are there
and scientists believe that
there are species that have many more
photoreceptors than just the three color
ones we humans have
which by the way not all humans see the
world in the same way some of us are
colorblind to various degrees
and
very often we don't even agree on small
things like if a dress on the Internet
is blue and black or white and gold
but my favorite creature or one of my
favorite creatures is the peacock Manta
shrimp which is estimated to have 12 to
16 photoreceptors and that indicates the
world to them might look so much more
colorful
so what about artificial intelligence
can AI help us see beyond our human
capabilities
well I've been working with AI for the
past five years
and in my experience it can see within
the data it gets fed
but then you might be wondering okay
if AI can't help imagine anything new
why would an artist see any point in
using it
and my answer to that is because I think
that it can help augment our creativity
as there's value in creating
combinations of known elements to form
new ones
and this boundary of what we can imagine
based on what we have experienced is the
place that I have been exploring for me
it started with jellyfish on a screen at
an aquarium and wearing those old 3D
glasses which I hope you remember the
ones with the blue and red lens
and this experience made me want to
recreate their textures but not just
that I also wanted to create new
jellyfish that I hadn't seen before like
these
and was starting with jellyfish very
quickly escalated to other sea creatures
like cnemoni coral and fish
and then from there came amphibians
birds and insects
and this became a series called neural
Zoo
but when you look closely
what do you see there's no single
creature in these images
and AI augments my creative process by
allowing me to distill and recombine
textures and that's something that would
otherwise take me months to draw by hand
plus I'm actually terrible at drawing
so you could say in a way what I'm doing
is a contemporary version of something
that humans have already been doing for
a long time even before cameras existed
in medieval times people went on
Expeditions and when they came back they
would share about what they saw to an
illustrator and the illustrator having
never seen what was being described
would end up drawing based on the
creatures that they had previously seen
and in the process creating like hybrid
animal of some sort
so an Explorer might describe a beaver
but having never seen one the
illustrator might give it the head of a
rodent the body of a dog and a fish-like
tail
in the series artificial Natural History
I took thousands of illustrations from a
natural history archives and I fed them
to a neural network to generate new
versions of them
but up until now all my work was done in
2D
and with the help of my studio partner
felican McCormick we decided to train a
neural network on a data set of 3D
scanned beetles
but I must warn you that our first
results were extremely blurry and they
looked like the blobs you see here
and this could be due to many reasons
but one of them being that there aren't
really a lot of openly available data
sets of 3D insects and also we were
repurposing a neural network that
normally gets used to generate images
to generate 3D so believe it or not
these are very exciting blobs to us
voice time and some very high key
Solutions like data augmentation where
we threw in ants and other beetle-like
insects to enhance the data set we ended
up getting this
which we've been told they look like
grilled chicken
but hungry for more we pushed our
technique and eventually they ended up
looking like this
we use something called 3D star transfer
to map textures onto them and we also
trained a natural language model to
generate scientific like names and
anatomical descriptions
and eventually we even found a network
architecture that could handle 3D meshes
so they ended up looking like this
and for us this became a way of creating
kind of a speculative study
thank you
a speculative study of creatures that
never existed kind of like a speculative
biology
but I didn't want to talk about Ai and
its potential unless it brought me
closer to a real species
which of these do you think is easier to
find data about online
yeah well as you guessed correctly the
red panda
and this maybe could be due to many
reasons but one of them being how cute
they are
which means we photograph and talk about
them a lot
unlike the Boreal for liking
but both of them are classified as
endangered
so I wanted to bring visibility to other
endangered species that don't get the
same amount of digital representation
attitude fluffy red panda
and to do this we trained an AI on
millions of images of the natural world
and then we prompted with text to
generate some of these creatures
so when prompted with a text
an image of a critically endangered
spider the peacock tarantula and its
scientific name are model generated this
and here's an image of the real peacock
tarantula which is a wonderful spider in
the mid to India
but when prompted with a text an image
of a critically endangered bird The
Mangrove Finch our model generated this
and here's a photo of the real Mangrove
Finch
both these creatures exist in the wild
but the accuracy of each generated image
is fully dependent on the data available
these cameras offer everyday data to me
are a different way of how the future
could be
not in a literal sense perhaps but
in the sense that through practicing the
expanding of our own imagination about
the ecosystems we are a part of
we might just be better equipped to
recognize New Opportunities and
potential
knowing that there's a boundary to our
imagination doesn't have to feel
limiting
on the contrary it can help motivate us
to expand that boundary further and to
seek out colors and things we haven't
yet seen
and perhaps and reach our imagination as
a result so thank you
[Applause]